right the client will now proceed to
read the orders of the day
I this position for me the as I
understand it my our right honorable
friend the member for sanit North is
likely to be able to take the chair
later today during these proceedings
Kenny confirm that he won't be able to
take the chair until we have disposed of
the first bill on the order paper
because he spoke in quite uh vehement
terms on second reading in that debate
so Christopher sit down don't worry I've
got the point you don't need to labor it
the answer is anybody who takes this
chair is completely neutral independent
like all honorable members I have faith
and I have the Trust In anybody who sits
in this church I cannot believe that
some people question that in the same
way with the panel of church we have
faith and trust and I know that you've
got faith interest and you wouldn't even
want to proceed on that basis like let
us know
hunting trophies import prohibition Bill
not amended in the public bill committee
to be considered
before we go on to procedures remain
members of the difference between report
stage and third reading the scope of the
report stage is a debate about the
Amendments I've selected the scope of
the third reading debate to follow will
be the whole bill as it stands after
that stage members who wish to consider
these points and then decide at which
stage or stage is they won't try and
catch my eye
we will begin with new Clause one with
which it will be convenient to consider
all new clause and amendments as on the
selection paper but just before I do
come I would just say it is also in the
hands of the Arnold member for
Christchurch to get this bill through
very quickly so he has no worries so
Bill wiggin
thank you Mr Speaker it's very good to
see you in the chat uh new Clause one
I'd like to move which concerns the
duration of this act and would cause the
provisions of the bill to cease to have
effects five years after the ACT has
passed
Mr Speaker we stood on a Manifesto
commitment in 2019 to ban imports from
trophy hunting of endangered animals I
therefore proposed that the sunset
Clause be added for the very simple
purpose of ensuring that should the ACT
prove unsuccessful in protecting
endangered species it can be withdrawn
if on the other hand after five years
this act does in fact prove to be
successful in achieving the stated aim
in our Manifesto commitment the
secretary of state would have the power
to extend the expiration date by up to
five years I have been concerned
throughout the progress of this bill
however that it is not motivated by a
desire to see African Wildlife flourish
and prosper if it were then it would
have paid heed to the scientific
evidence provided by experts in
conservation
British conservationist Professor Amy
Dickman and Adam Hart have argued that
90 of protected areas with lions are
severely underfunded removing trophy
hunting without providing a suitable
alternative of Revenue will expose those
underfunded protected areas to further
risks such as poaching according to the
iucn Red List trophy hunting is not
considered to be a threat driving any
species to Extinction instead trophy
hunting generates revenue for
anti-poaching and habitat conservation
it has been recognized as a tool a
positive tool for conservation in
multiple species including black rhino
White Rhino agalee macko and some
populations of Lyle while white tail
deer as well as maintaining extensive
areas of wildlife habitat
in a joint letter from high
commissioners of Namibia South Africa
Tanzania and Zimbabwe to the minister of
State in the foreign office they argue
well-managed trophy hunting the
prevailing model in all our countries
contributes to reductions in habitat
loss and poaching it has proved as a as
a demonstrable conservation tool for
multiple species including endangered
ones such as Black Rhinos Maxi Louis the
director of Nasco the namibian
association of cbrm which is community a
renewable
support organizations in a letter to
honorable members to The Honorable
member for Crawley wrote
take away those employed to protect
wildlife in the reserves and poachers
move into the vacuum this quickly leads
to huge losses of endangered animals yet
what really angers us is how these
animals die
snaring leads to appalling injuries and
pitifully slow deaths poisoning is
traumatic Lions vomiting for hours as
they pass away she wrote that when
Botswana had a temporary ban on paid
hunting there was a 593 increase in
fresh elephant carcasses being found
Professor Amy Dickman a conservation
biologist and director of wildlife
conservation research at the University
of Oxford has also argued that this bill
will facilitate an increase in poaching
she's described her distress while
carrying out field work in Africa where
she witnessed the horrendous aftermath
of a lioness trapped in a poached snare
a decapitated hyena and a leopard with
its poor mangled in a trap all of which
had suffered more painful and prolonged
deaths from poachers than from a
hunter's bullet the concern held by both
conservationists and African Community
leaders is that enforcing the removal of
the vital source of Revenue supplied by
Trophy Hunters to these communities we
open the floodgates to poachers who will
cause far more cruelty and pain to the
animals and will pose a far greater
threat to endangered species
the opinions and evidence from these
experts do not fill me with a lot of
confidence that the bill will achieve
its stated aim nor does the amount of
misinformation that is being touted by
the campaign to ban trophy hunting
so I've introduced this Clause to ensure
that this bill is not a classic case of
virtue signaling at the expense of
African wildlife and the conservation
efforts of African people in five years
down the line the ACT proves to be
ineffective as I suspect it will at
conserving endangered species and has
led to an increase in poaching then it
seems right to me that provision should
be made for the ACT to be withdrawn if
the supporters of this bill are so
confident that this act will achieve the
desired result of protecting endangered
species and not encouraging the poachers
who I believe are a greater threat to
these endangered species than
well-regulated funding then why not
include the Sun cause in the bill I will
give up course
can I ask him how much in percentage
terms does trophy hunting provide to
give the Protectors of wildlife
um an income the the budget what are how
much of a budget comes from Trophy
Hunter all of it
um because because one of the problems
Wheels which will I will come to in a
moment is that where we are asking
people to stop trophy hunting we're not
necessarily replacing that with funding
um and and in one area which I'm looking
forward to telling the house about in a
moment we do provide funding but we're
trying to encourage local people to
protect their wildlife and build a
businesses particularly for the women
and and then they are arguing that by
withdrawing trophy hunting we are
cutting the legs off that effort so
there are real contradictions here and
that's why it's such a difficult subject
of course I'm very grateful
Can it can you confirm that Vernon Booth
a conservationist and Wildlife
consultant in Zimbabwe writing in
today's Daily Mail has said that revenue
from a trophy hunting contributes 25 of
the income of the Zimbabwe Parks and
Wildlife Management Authority
yes I have no reason to to disagree with
that and I think that um it just
demonstrates what a thorny issue this is
and it's worth remembering that this is
a bill designed to stop the importing of
trophies rather than prevent the Banning
of hunting which is why I'd like to
speak to new Clause 2 regarding the
implantation and monitoring which is
similar to new Clause one in that its
intention is to assess the practicality
and effectiveness of the provisions of
this act it would require a statement
sorry it would be a requirement that
within years or three years of the ACT
being passed the secretary of state must
labor for Parliament a report on its
implementation and the effectiveness of
its Provisions including an impact
assessment that the actors had on the
conservation of endangered species
as a as the UK is a member of the
international Union for conservation of
nature we should follow its
recommendations before restricting
trophy hunting these include a sound
analysis of the conservation role of
trophy hunting meaning consultation with
effective governments and communities
steps to address poor practice and
implementation of feasible fully funded
Alternatives which generate equal or
greater conservation benefits
since I don't believe that these steps
have been adequately taken it's only
right that this proposed amendment is
adopted to ensure the effectiveness of
the act in promoting conservation of
endangered species in measured three
years which is measured in three years
after the implementation of the ACT I
can see no reason if there's such
confidence in the act that it will
contribute to the conservation of such
species for there to be any objection to
a post-implementation review being
undertaken which examines the impact on
species abroad
in order to test the efficacy of the
legislation whether it's achieved the
desired goal of improving the population
numbers of endangered species I hope
that the house will consider this new
clause which would ensure we continue to
keep the effectiveness of the bill under
review until it's enacted
new Clause 3 is a reporting requirement
for the Secretary of State to assess the
impact of provisions on Northern Ireland
which has put forward by my honorable
friend who I have to say has been a
tremendous Ally in this and if I were to
occupy a foxhole perhaps in Ukraine I
could ask for no finer colleague to join
me than he so I uh I want to thank my my
honor friend for tabling section three
of the bill makes it clear that though
the bill extends to Northern Ireland it
does not actually apply there and I
wonder if my right elephant therefore
agree with me that considering the
delicate nature of the Northern Ireland
protocol requiring the Secretary of
State to provide the house with as much
information as possible on the impact of
the bill on Imports then this would be a
sensible measure
I'm also grateful to my right honorable
friend for tabling new Clause 4 which
seeks to introduce an Advisory board on
trophy hunting and I think this is a
really helpful step forward and I'm glad
that we've had productive talks with the
government on this and that they
recognize that this would be a sensible
inclusion in the bill in principle I
support the introduction of The Advisory
Board whose role would be to advise the
Secretary of State on matters relating
to the import of hunting trophies to
Great Britain if the aim of the bill was
to prevent the hunting of endangered
animals then expert advice on Hunting
trophies that have been derived from a
species of animal which appear to be or
even likely to become endangered is very
welcome
in my opinion it's vital that we keep
the focus on endangered species at the
heart of this bill since that is after
all the aim much of the information that
has been presented at second reading of
this bill has been analyzed by Dr Dennis
Rowe and Professor Adam Hart they have
found that out of over 150 statements
made by MPS in support of the ban 70
were factually incorrect or misleading
likewise much of the public campaigning
and lobbying that has been done by high
profile actors and celebrities who
actually have very little expertise in
this matter
I'd be delighted to give way
um I thank them for giving away
thank you
um I think some of the statistics that
certainly I've been sent around this
bill
um have been obviously produced uh from
a very biased on both sides of a biased
and is that not the case we shouldn't
Pander to a table that we've been sent
that's obviously from a hunting Lobby or
it's a compliment animal we need to get
the most sensible in the Middle where
we're considering and a lot of uh The
Honorable gentleman's points are
obviously using the statistics um from
one side but dismissing those of the
other
well I haven't used very many statistics
Mr Speaker to be fair because I I fully
agree with my honorable friend
um this was analysis done on statements
made by myself included in the debate
before and if 70 were factually
incorrect or misleading then who judges
that well obviously the people to judge
it are experts and the experts should be
peer reviewed acknowledged and
acceptable to everybody and that's why
this one Amendment which I think is very
very important allows the government to
have access to agreed experts which I
think will be much more helpful much
more um
factually useful and will take perhaps
some of the emotion out of what is a
very very emotional subject
um because I think well yes
uh thank you thank you Mr Speaker I
think we um we're all United in this
house and they're trying to protect
endangered African wildlife and I myself
have been uh seen a lot of it out in the
wild and I actually applaud those
efforts well there is clearly a
disagreement about is the uh the best
way to do that and indeed all these
statistics which uh there's debate about
and I've got lots of Statistics which I
won't bother quoting because no one will
believe it my simple question really is
this that if your argument is that you
need trophy upington to continue to
provide funding for conservation efforts
if that is the only reason to allow the
continue of trophy hunting
um then shouldn't really the pressure be
put on this government but also
internationally to ensure there are
other routes of funding to ensure
conservation efforts because it surely
cannot be right that actually the main
way to fund conservation of endangered
species is to allow the killing of
endangered species
I'm very grateful I I'm
mindful that new Clause before doesn't
stray beyond what new Clause 4 does
which is to try and get a team of
experts to advise the government so that
his point which I think is very valid is
part of that calculation by the
Secretary of State
um because public campaigning and
lobbying done by high prior high profile
actors and celebrities who have very
little experience in these matters but
whose voices seem to speak louder due to
their Fame than due to the African
Community leaders and scientific experts
who have objected to the bill and I
think we need to take away the Heat and
the anger from this and get back to the
expertise the science and the results
that as he rightly says the whole house
wants which is that we protect
endangered species so I think it's only
right that if this bill receives Royal
assent then the government should have
to consult with experts in conservation
to ensure that the aim of the
legislation is respected I'd be most
grateful to the ministry if she can
provide provide some Assurance to
African Community leaders who've
objected to this bill in their letters
to the government that their expertise
on this matter is respected and
incorporated into such an Advisory Board
this would ensure a positive
consultation is maintained with the
country's most affected by this bill
namely in Africa who have thus so far
taken offense from MPS telling their
Democratic countries how to manage their
Wildlife without listening to what they
have to say I wholeheartedly support the
introduction of this Clause into the
bill to ensure an ongoing and productive
consultation is had between the
government and the people who will be on
the receiving end as he as my honorable
friend mentioned of the effects of this
bill
I'll be delighted
honorable
I Thank The Honorable gentlemen for
giving way but professing myself to be a
little confused by the argument he makes
about us seeking to undermine the role
of African leaders my understanding of
the proposed bill is a ban on Imports
here not a ban on trophy hunting in
those countries but a ban in this
country on Imports is that not the case
I I I absolutely agree with his
understanding unfortunately it isn't
quite as straightforward as that the
purpose of the bill reaches beyond what
the UK imports and exports because we
already have a permitting system that
allows us to manage that so this is more
than that this is a proper ban and
therefore the people who are expected to
be on the receiving end are the people
who would benefit from new Clause 4
being added to the bill which would give
some opportunity for them to consult
amendment number six aims to ban sorry
enter to limit the ban on trophies that
are in breach of society's permit
requirements Amendment 12 and I'm again
grateful to my friend The Honorable
gentleman for member of Christchurch for
tabling Amendment 12 which exempts the
countries of Botswana and Namibia South
Africa Tanzania Zambia Zimbabwe from the
band based on their records of
conservation
I will
try and make some progress because I
believe that the government has been
exceptionally uh helpful on this and
therefore I think the the amendment that
most matters is is amendment number one
so if I can just get to that part of my
notes I will seek to Enlighten the house
as to why I'd be delighted to give away
while I'm Shuffling my papers no thank
you Mr Speaker the happy St Patrick's
Day too I was reflecting that
um perhaps the animals that are uh being
hunted as trophies are not the only
endangered species
um around here I think there are several
of them on the government benches as
well in the shape of in the shape of
conservative members of parliament but I
hope he recognizes and I think it's I
think it's I hope he recognizes and I
think it's I think it's unfair to
suggest otherwise that many of our
constituents do feel very passionately
about this that the scope of the bill is
as the other honorable member has just
said limited to Bringing these trophies
into the United Kingdom no one's trying
to tell a sovereign government and what
they should be doing in their own
countries but we should take a
cognizance of what is being brought into
this country and many people many of the
conceptions in Glasgow North that I have
heard from are extremely concerned about
the trade uh that the practice of trophy
hunting and the trade in such trophies
and I think it's important we recognize
that strength of feeling and it's good
that he's bringing these amendments in a
constructive manner because I think the
last thing constituents would want to
see is parliamentary game playing and
undermining of the private members Bill
system
well
quickly grateful to The Honorable
Jennifer for his very helpful
Intervention which allowed me to shuffle
my papers and I agree with him I think
the people who are concerned by this
bill are kind-hearted they want to make
sure that animals are safe and protected
and they've got a very good vehicle in
in my honorable friend uh the member for
Crawley's Bill to express that the
problem with the road to hell is that it
is paved with good intentions and what
none of us I think in the whole house
want to see is any reduction in the
habitat and the success of endangered
species in their recovery and therefore
this bill I hope will not
um
achieve my my fears which is that it
would undermine that successful route
but instead
um we can come together agree a bill
that allows this to pass through the
house and to that end Amendment one is
the one which I think is most important
because Amendment one seeks to restrain
the Secretary of State because I know
this one's tremendous but I can't
predict who it might be in the future
and therefore it would restrict the
Secretary of State to the
species listed on the face of the bill
the ones that we are all concerned about
so it would remove the power of this
extra state to vary by statutory
instrument the species to which this act
applies it would close the loophole that
grants the Secretary of State the power
to extend the ACT to animals which are
not considered endangered and I'm
concerned that this power could go
beyond our 2019 Manifesto commitment
that promised to ban the import of
hunting trophies from endangered animals
something that our constituents did vote
for so I thank the government for
engaging me with with me so positively
on this and I believe that we can move
forward constructively if we adopt this
amendment it would keep the scope of the
bill to species listed in Annex A or B
of the principal Wildlife trade
regulation under the principal trial uh
Wildlife trade regulation all Society
species are listed in four annexes
according to their varying levels of
protection
Annex a of the principal Wildlife trade
regulation which includes all society's
appendix one species and some Society
suspendix two species list the most
endangered species those which are
either threatened with Extinction or so
rare that any level of trade would
imperil the survival of the species this
includes the hunting leopard the Indian
lion black and white rhino apart from
those in South Africa where numbers are
higher Annex B includes all other
societies appendix 2 species as well as
some other species but predominantly
species threatened by commercial trade
for instance the African elephant the
African Lion some white rhinos some
brown bears and the American black bear
would fall into this classification
granting the Secretary of State power to
vary by statutory instrument the species
to which this act applies would allow
species that are not listed in cities
and are not endangered to fall within
the scope of the bill
in fact um that this was brought to my
attention in the uh conclusions of the
second reading debate when the minister
said the government intends to table
instruments that would cover species of
concern and that would cover other
animals
um which which really Disturbed me uh
bikes by the British people did not vote
for an indiscriminate ban on shooting
any animal that the Secretary of State
might choose to name they voted to
protect endangered species and that's
what I hope this bill will do uh
I don't think uh Mr Speaker I need to go
on if the government is uh willing to
accept Amendment one I think I can pause
and allow some of my friends and
colleagues to contribute if the minister
would like to intervene I'd be delighted
to know if the amendment one is
acceptable to the government otherwise
we can talk about amendment 14 which
leaves out the power of the Secretary of
State to specify animals or species to
which the prohibition of applies but of
course that very much does a similar job
to Amendment one
and Amendment 23 uh a giveaway happily
and The Honorable uh gentleman for
giving way I would like to confirm that
the government is
[Music]
is both new clothes for and Amendment
one
um for reasons I will go into later
during this debate but I'm pleased to
understand I think that the remaining 30
amendments put forward will not be moved
by The Honorable gentleman
I'm extremely grateful to my friend the
minister I think she's been about as
helpful as any Minister I've ever had
the pleasure of working with and I'm
sure the whole house will join me in
celebrating my ability to withdraw my
amendments apart from the two that she's
just mentioned thank you Mr Speaker
who's going to read it
are you moving yeah
I'm sorry speaker I didn't hear you
nucleus one
duration of this act not moved
well in that case we
were really nice
the new course for Advisory board on
Hunting trophies
thank you
the question is
the question is that there'll be no red
a second time
and before I just bring in just to
clarify something that was said and it's
purely a clarification the bill is only
limited to the UK that's what's being
asked for so those who think it was what
I did just for the clarification of
public verification it would only affect
this country and not other countries
right we know come to New Clause four
Mr Christopher job to move forward
there we are the question is to do class
four we read a second time as many of
that opinions
oh we're having a debate so Henry or
Henderson uh Mr speaker thank you very
much indeed uh it is a privilege to be
able to rise in this debate and respond
to uh the Clauses and amendments that my
right honorable friends the members for
North Hereford and Christchurch have
proposed uh today uh I'm very grateful
uh for the constructive way in which the
government and my rice honorable friends
uh have been in consultation on these
amendments and new Clauses and I uh Mr
Speaker and I'm happy to accept new
Clause 4 the establishment of an
Advisory board on how a trophy hunting
Imports ban operates when it is Law and
indeed Amendment one which
would allow discretion for the Secretary
of State to add species I think that
actually new clause for an Advisory
Board covers off a lot of the concerns
that my writable friend the member
thought North Hereford has set out I'm
in no doubt Mr Speaker and I trust that
across this house we want to see the
best conservation of endangered species
around the world whether that be in
Africa or anywhere else North America
other parts of Asia other parts of the
world as well because this bill is not
just about the importation uh the
Banning of endangered species body parts
into this country from Africa but from
endangered species from around the world
um I know that my riserable friend has
withdrawn the amendments in terms of the
sunset clause or monitoring on how it
would work with regards to Northern
Ireland and again I think new Clause 4
and Advisory Board actually covers off a
lot of those concerns so Mr Speaker I am
pleased to support those new Clauses and
amendments and welcome the fact that the
governments have helped me in working
constructively I give ways
I'm glad the member has mentioned the
issue of Northern Ireland and perhaps
because at racist the committee stage uh
with the ee law applying in Northern
Ireland of course the importation of
trophies could come through Northern
Ireland Irish Republic in the Northern
Ireland and then
um across from Northern Ireland the GP I
kind of a back doorway of circumventing
the important provisions of this bill
what assurances has he had that that
back door can be firmly locked so that
trophies cannot come into Northern
Ireland and through Northern Ireland
into the rest of the United Kingdom
grateful to that intervention I think
the response to that in detail needs to
come from the minister of the crown and
not a uh a simple back Woodsman
backbencher in this house but I have had
assurances uh from
um members of the government
that the Northern Ireland situation will
not become some sort of back door or
some sort of stepping stone for
endangered species to be able to be
introduced into Great Britain through
some sort of Northern Ireland route the
protocol the winds agreement subject to
agreement of course in this house uh
next week and the United Kingdom
internal Market act should cover off any
of those concerns but of course I defer
to my honorable friend the minister who
no doubt will be addressing those
concerns in a moment so uh Madam Deputy
speaker in a conclusion I'm happy to
support new Clause 4 and Amendment one
I'm grateful for those other I think 30
amendments new Clauses uh being
withdrawn and I hope that we can move on
to ensuring that this legislation to
protect
uh the most endangered species in the
world
and Britain playing its parts full Parts
in doing that can proceed to its next
phases both here today and later on in
the other place thank you
mad madame
dip I'm very grateful to my honorable
friend for saying that he supports uh
new clause for the the background to
this has been explained that there are
diametrically opposed expert opinions on
what would be a good hunting ban of
trophies and what would not be and I
think it's important that this debate
should be informed by the facts and the
science and to that extent I hope that
by accepting new Clause 4 we will give a
sum a Solace to for example
um Dr dilis Rowe the chair of the iucn
sustainable use in livelihoods
Specialist Group and Professor Adam Hart
who's a member of that Specialist Group
who wrote on the 22nd of February to the
both my right honorable friend the the
Secretary of State for the environment
food and Royal Affairs but also to the
executive state for foreign affairs
setting out their concerns about the
bill and the risk that the United
Kingdom government might be taking of
ignoring the science scientific evidence
and thereby actively harming
conservation globally and they said that
it's now for the sake of wildlife all
over the world now is the time to listen
to quieter more informed voices and I
think that by setting up such an
advisory
panel that will be facilitated and I'm
I'm delighted that the the government
has indicated that it is going to
support that Madam Deputy speaker
this agreement about the objectives and
but there is no agreement about the
means by which those objectives should
be achieved the objective being to in
protect endangered species and actually
to encourage the Revival of those
species and that's that's why I I've I
think that we've made a lot of progress
uh today but can I also draw attention
to my new clause three I've made it
clear that I'm not going to force this
to a boot but new Clause 3 and deals
with the problem that this bill fails to
deliver in full on the conservative
party Manifesto commitment because that
commitment was to ban the import of
hunting trophies from endangered animals
into the United Kingdom
my honorable friends Bill the long title
makes it clear that it's only limited to
making provision prohibiting the import
of hunting trophies into Great Britain
and Northern Ireland is excluded from
its scope and that prevented me tabling
amendments to extend the bill to the
whole of the United Kingdom
but this aspect of the debate uh
featured in a report on page 14 of
yesterday's Daily Telegraph and a
commentary by Serrano fines who was
asking about what is the point in
election manifest is that MPS don't vote
for what's
in it Edward Eduardo con Chavez founder
of the campaign to ban trophy hunting is
quoted as saying that they are aware of
groups from Northern Ireland who are
shooting threatened species and are
bringing their heads and bodies back
home he says I quote the need this needs
to be stopped exiting the EU made it
possible for the UK to introduce World
beating legislation to ban hunting
trophies it would be a travesty if the
bill were not to apply to the whole of
the item Kingdom because of unfinished
business with brexit it's a Pity amount
of Deputy speaker that uh if Mr Kung
chauvin's felt so strongly about this
that he didn't actually criticize the
limiting long title of the bill or when
it was first introduced on the 15th of
June uh last year
um he is however correct to highlight
that under the Northern Ireland protocol
and the proposed Windsor framework the
European Union single Market rules will
still apply in Northern Ireland raising
fears as Northern Ireland and could
become indeed a back door to get the
trophies to Rich plants in Britain and
Dodge the ban he he says that a hunting
trophies could be stopped from entering
Northern Ireland overnight with a stroke
of a pen
the secretary of state would only need
to issue a ministerial decree stating
that he or she will no longer sign
import permits I'd be interested by them
different speakers to hear from my
honorable or right honorable friends uh
from the Department
what they think about that suggestion
um if correct it could also
um surely apply to the whole of the
United Kingdom thereby making the need
for this legislation
um totally redundant but can I ask the
the minister specifically to comment on
the assertion that France and the
Netherlands have used ministerial
decrees to ban trophies because single
Market rules prevented them legislating
is that correct is it also correct that
Belgium and Finland are considering
doing the same and would it be possible
for the United Kingdom to do likewise we
don't normally try to legislate by
decree although I noticed that the that
the president of France is trying to do
just just sat in his own country at the
moment but so I I'm a bit I'm a bit
skeptical about where what can be done
to deal with the problem raised in in
the fact that this does not apply uh to
the whole of the United Kingdom and
that's why I put forward
um new Clause 3 which would have
actually uh required
um the government to report on the
implications of what was happening in
Northern Ireland so that in due course
um it would be properly informed as to
whether or not legislative action was
needed to address
um any loopholes or
anti-anti avoidance
um and so I'm disappointed the
government's not prepared to accept new
Clause uh three but
um it's uh
I conclude both asking that putting the
challenge to the to the government what
solution does the minister have to the
Daily Telegraph headline open inverter
come as brexit loophole allows import of
Hippo heads and stuffed Tigers because I
do think quite a lot of people will be
wanting to have a clear answer to that
question and I don't think it's
forthcoming with this bill which applies
only to Great Britain and not to
Northern Ireland I won't go into all the
other amendments that I've put down but
I do think that
what the the compromise in the sense
which is what it is that is now emerging
we should
um be of some help to our friends in
those six African countries who have
expressed outrage in their letter to the
government about the implications of
this bill for those countries we make
much in this house of the importance of
soft uh Power and I think that we need
to start thinking more about what we can
do to engage positively those countries
in Africa that actually abstained in the
recent United Nations general assembly
vote calling for Russia's immediate
withdrawal from Ukraine and Angola
Namibia South Africa Zimbabwe Mozambique
Uganda we need Madame Deputy speaker in
my view to work much more more closely
and positively with the governments in
those countries instead of letting them
think that they are alienated and are
viewed by us as being
subject to sort of colonial control
which is the essence of the complaint
that's been made to uh both the
Minnesota state of the foreign and
Commonwealth office who's dealing with
development but also to the to the
foreign secretary so let's see if we can
work with those countries listen to try
and understand them and then we might
find it easier to prevent them falling
into the hands of the China and the
Soviet influence which they seem to be
tempted to do at the moment because they
are being neglected so I think that this
compromise has great potential for
improving uh foreign relations between
our country and those countries in
southern Africa based upon a better
understanding of the need to
protect our Wildlife but also to do so
in a sustainable way that fits in with
the local economy so Madam Deputy
speaker this is um in the sense an
historic day for for me because it looks
as though the government's going to
accept one of my amendments yeah yeah
and uh so um I I I don't think I'm going
to say anything else in case they change
their mind
Minister Trudy house
thank you very much Madam Deputy speaker
and thanks to all colleagues who are
both here in the debate in the house uh
speaking today but also colleagues
um who have played their part in making
this possible and in particular I want
to pay particular thanks uh to The
Honorable member for Crawley who has
demonstrated such diligence
professionalism and courage because
there are strong incredible arguments
across this debate but to speak to
um nc4 and Amendment one I shall be
brief Madam Deputy speaker because we
have an awful lot to get through as I
have previously said I support both in
turn new Clause 4 table by the honorable
member for Christ Church I must commend
the principle of receiving expert advice
on this matter especially given the
credible and variable uh discussions and
absolutely in recognition that in some
cases money does come from trophy
hunting which supports conversation
conservation that is not in all cases
and I would like to set out very briefly
what more we are currently doing and how
we will continue to support those
countries
um later in my
um third reading speech in terms of
amendment one table by the honorable of
the north herefordshire I also support
this amendment in doing so Madam Deputy
speaker I would like to stress my
support for the internationally agreed
system
undecides for identifying listing and
protecting species that are endangered
threatened or potentially at risk from
International Trade including the trade
of hunting trophies that is why the
reference to Annex A and B covers
thousands of species around 6 000
species among them those iconic species
we know are targeted for trophies of
course with this band we go beyond
sightings and that is the right thing to
do and it's why we are here
the questions that new Clause 4 be read
a second time as many as are of that
opinion say aye the country no I think
the eyes have it the eyes have it the
question is that new Clause 4 be added
to the bill as many as are of that
opinion say
aye the country no I think the eyes have
it the eyes have it uh Amendment one
Seville we're going to move formally I'd
like to move forward the question is the
amendment that the amendment be made as
many as are of that opinion say I
the country know and I think the eyes
have it the eyes have it
consideration completed third reading
what day now
the question is that the bill being I
read the third time uh Henry
[Music]
thank you madam Deputy speaker I beg to
move that the hunting trophies import
prohibition Bill be now read a third
time I am extraordinarily grateful uh to
you madam Deputy speaker and all
honorable and right honorable members
here today who have been present to
ensure that we are supporting the
conservation of some of the world's most
endangered species not only from Africa
some of those iconic species uh like
lion and giraffe and rhinoceroses but
also other parts of the world uh polar
bears in North America as well to be
clear the territorial extent of this
bill is Great Britain it is about
not allowing the importation of hunted
body parts of endangered species
as you know I'm a support group of the
bill and this is great news at this
building is going through this house
today with so much support within in the
house the point he's just touched on is
absolutely critical there's been a lot
of false information out this is about
our territorial rules it's not telling
other countries what to do this is not
Colonial this is actually saying this is
what we will allow into our country it's
entirely up to other countries what they
want to do but this is about us and this
house
I'm grateful to my role friend for his
intervention and he anticipates some of
the remarks that I was about to say that
this is about the values that we in
Britain have that we do not want to be
part of a trade in endangered species uh
body parts we are not telling other
countries how to run their trade or
their conservation or hunting policies
although we may have a range of personal
opinions on this and it's important to
remember this that that this is about
those societies appendices one and two
species some almost six thousand species
of fauna and Flora who are endangered
that this legislation hopefully when it
enacted Madam Deputy speaker can play a
part in conserving I'd be delighted to
give away I'm grateful to him for giving
away he's been very generous in allowing
amendments to this bill has he received
any assurances from the members for
Christchurch or North Heritage here that
as he's now accepted the Amendments they
will not divide on third reading as he
knows I support this bill and I hope it
goes through without a division
I I sincerely hope that is the case and
right on cue I'm sure I can
but I love the way the house is
listening rather carefully to this yes I
think of uh there's no need to um to
divide the house this is a a Manifesto
commitment we are fulfilling it we've
improved the bill and I'm tremendously
grateful to the government for their
help
I'm grateful uh to uh my honorable
friend from North Hereford North
Hertfordshire for that uh contribution
um he is right this is a Manifesto
commitment indeed this is a commitment
that all uh major parties in this house
have signed up to and I think that is a
very important point to stress and I
sincerely hope that the other place will
hear what this elected house has said
with regard to this legislation I'll be
on a honest giveaway and I want to
congratulate him on the work he's done
to get this bill thus far and I hope it
gets through today could we just perhaps
he could join the rest of us in
congratulating all those many
campaigners or around the country that
have worked so hard to draw attention to
the issue of trophy hunting and ensure
that we've got such a
good attendance here today and that in
itself becomes an education to people to
understand that we can play our part in
conservation of beautiful and endangered
species by passing this bill today
I'm grateful to the contribution by the
original member from Islington uh he is
absolutely right people in this country
buy a clear majority opinion polling
shows between 80 and 90 percent of
people want to see this legislation come
through the people of this country care
passionately about conservation and the
environment and protecting endangered
species and it has been a long campaign
of many people from many different
backgrounds to ensure that this
legislation has come before Parliament
and it just would like to reiterate the
point that I hope that will be heard
across central Lobby in the other place
when this legislation hopefully leaves
this house later on this morning and
goes to them for consideration because
time is of the essence to help protect
endangered species uh Madame Deputy
speaker there are some many excellent
pieces of private members legislation
before this house today a and I don't
want to take any more time in delaying
that so I am grateful to all of those
who have supported this legislation and
and just in time
timing is everything in life Madame
Declan speaker would my honorable friend
join me in commending Eduardo konkarvis
for funding the campaign to ban trophy
hunting and revealing the sordidward of
kick sordid world of killing sentient
animals for entertainment there is
massive support in my needs constituency
and I congratulate him on bringing
forward this book well I'm grateful for
that message of congratulations and
indeed to highlight uh Eduardo for the
campaign efforts that he has led for so
many years to achieve this conservation
effort I would be delicious
it's just a quick point I'm quite sure I
find it distasteful to have a heads on
on walls to be honest but those heads
that are already on walls or rugs that
are already there they're not affected
by this bill at all this legislation uh
takes effect from
um when it is passed in and receives
Royal the center it is not retrospective
in that sense so with that Madam Deputy
speaker I uh I beg to move that this
bill the read a third time
question is that the bill be now read
the third time uh Sammy Wilson
thank you madam Deputy speaker and I do
wish to be very short on this uh let me
short speech
first of all I want to say that my party
is totally committed to this bill in
fact I was pleased to be a sponsor of
the the bill I'm pleased to have served
on the committee the one disappointment
that I do have is it because of the
existing Arrangements which the
government has with the EU where he
passed EU law and future EU law will
apply to Northern Ireland where Northern
Ireland remains part of the EU single
Market that this bill cannot apply to
Northern Ireland so first of all those
who wish to go trophy hunting and reside
in Northern Ireland can bring their
trophies back
and I think that that's to be part of
the United Kingdom but yet to find a law
which is supported by over 86 percent of
the UK population cannot apply in one
part of the United Kingdom is an offense
it's offensive to me and it's offensive
to many of the constituents who wrote to
me uh asking me to support this
legislation
the second thing it's a danger
because if as a result of Northern
Ireland remaining part of the EU single
market and EU law still applying there
so that UK law cannot apply
and part of the United Kingdom that's a
stark reality that we're facing here
um that Northern Ireland then could
become a back door for those who wish to
circumvent this legislation
people could bring their trophies into
Northern Ireland and because there's
frictionless trade from Northern Ireland
the GP could take them in and I would
like to hear from the minister I
understand that this they they
um sponsor of the bill uh was not able
to give the the answer because this is
something which perhaps the the minister
should have been addressing it was
raised at the committee stage and I
would like to have an assurance
my preference of course is that Northern
Ireland's possession within the United
Kingdom is fully restored
not something which is done by the
protocol not something which is done by
the winter framework
um either but that's my preference but
in the absence of that I would like to
hear from the minister what steps she
intends to take to ensure that this very
important well-supported worthwhile
legislation is not circumvented by the
fact that we have left part of the
United Kingdom half in the European
Union
Anthony Brown
I'm Deputy speaker I just want to uh put
on record my strong support for this
bill as a former environmentally
Observer and other times I've written a
lot about conservation of African
endangered species and also as a as a
private individual I've seen them a lot
uh in the wild and I can absolutely
confirm that the charismatic make
charismatic megaphone of Africa is one
of the true glories of uh our planet and
conserving them the endangered species
there is one of the greatest challenges
we Face uh for as a planet now
whatever the arguments about trophy
hunting whether it provides money for
conservation or not it surely cannot be
right that uh protecting these
endangered species relies on allowing
rich people to kill them it is not a
long-term sustainable solution and I
really urge the government going
forwards to do all that it can to make
sure that both the UK and
internationally ensures that
conservation efforts across African
countries and other areas where they're
endangered animals are properly funded
without having to rely on rich people
killing endangered animals thank you
speaker
I'm very pleased to see this roll return
to the chamber for his final comments
out so the honorable member for Crawley
has done an outstanding job and has been
a dedicated advocate for the course I'd
like to thank organizations and
individuals for their continued work in
the campaign to see this bill pass and
the briefings that they have provided I
have been disappointed to see the
persistent lobbying from certain
interest groups against this legislation
often intentionally based on
misinformation and hiding behind the
transparent in fallsville of
conservation
the mass representation of those
purporting to the conservationists is
something I spoke to in some detail at
second reading and I don't wish to
repeat myself here today what I will say
though is that it does not take much
scratching at the surface to see that
what many of these lobbies are looking
for is a conservation of hunting for
sport rather than anything environmental
and when you look at who is funding
their deeply biased works that will
become all clearer the second reading I
argued that trophy hunting is an ugly
relic of the colonial era what I would
add to that today is that is trophy
hunting and poaching is in fact illegal
for locals in these countries it is
ironic
that those looking to protect the highly
profitable Western white trophy hunting
tourist industry might find themselves
under the spotlight of that very same
Colonial accusation and to this point
I'd like to pay tribute to a man who
knows firsthand the positive impact of
hunting bands to protect his country's
beautiful Wildlife former president of
Botswana Ian Karma any urged colleagues
today to support this bill and his words
to Halt The Reckless cruel destruction
of the world's wonderful Wildlife by
Nature's enemies
the UK government and more importantly
the UK public have every right to decide
that they don't want these Macabre
mangled animal body parts entering the
country or circulating here for profit
and this is what the bill ultimately
will achieve and as we have heard it
doesn't change the law in other
countries or outlaw hunting there
polling has shown unequivocally that the
British public including many of my
constituents support an outright ban on
trophy Imports and do not support
proposals for any partial ban or smart
bans in 2020 the government consulted on
Banning the import of hunting trophies
and at subsequent policy statement said
within the consultation we asked for
that exemption should be considered for
example for conservation reasons we note
the strength of sentiment from those who
do who did not support exemptions and
there will be no exemptions for hunting
trophies from species and scope of the
ban so it's clear that some of the
exemptions that some members were trying
to include in this bill were not in
keeping with public feeling the public
feeling the government were able to test
through public consultation so it's also
clear that including any exemptions to a
ban would undermine the very purpose of
the legislation where we allow loopholes
to exists we also allow people to find
ways to exploit them
I think it's fair to say that
participants of this Sport come from one
main demographic and that's rich white
men and sometimes rich white women and
it's that same demographic the proceeds
benefit
looking to protect the financial
interests at the cost of the existence
of some of the world's most beautiful
animals the conservation of natural
resources and wildlife in Africa and its
communities I urge all colleagues from
across both benches to throw their full
support Behind The Honorable member for
Crawley and his bill it's critical and
overdue change for the better
uh yes okay if you could stand who are
trying to catch my eye that was a bit
confusing last night it's only one
person so Bill wiggin thank you I am
most grateful I will keep my comments
fairly brief I was very happy enjoying
the debate up until the uh honorable
lady who poked the bear so to speak and
I also just say how nice it was to hear
from the former leader of the labor
party and we'd like to hear more from
him more frequently
because like him I am very very
sensitive about racism and I spoke out
against this bill because I
fundamentally believed that it was a
near Colonial attempt to control
conservation Management Programs of
African Democratic countries I know that
not one of us here today is a racist or
has that uh really nasty uh streak of
wanting to judge people by the color of
their skin but we have to be desperately
careful that we don't signal that we
know best to countries that are emerging
and uh representatives from Angola
Botswana Namibia and Zambia who are
involved with the conservation
activities in what's called Kaza the
kovango Zambezi trans Frontier
conservation Africa commented what
rights do they have to impose
restrictions that will damage our
wildlife and people now the UK
government supports Casa through funding
and yet ethical hunting is part of the
ambitious five African nation
conservation Endeavor to provide habitat
and connectivity for wildlife across
borders in an area of over 110 million
Acres which is double the size of the
United Kingdom and therefore this bill
does have a contradictory effect on our
policy towards supporting African
conservation efforts and that is why I'm
really grateful to the government for
accepting new Clause 4
in the second reading of the bill one of
the members described the UK as a world
leader in nature conservation however a
global League table for efforts to
conserve Mega fauna or large animals
puts pro-hunting Botswana Namibia and
Tanzania first second and third in the
world and in contrast the UK is 123rd so
it's really really important that we get
this right I I know that many honorable
members who watched David Attenborough
on television uh David Attenborough have
recently described one of the most the
UK as one of the most nature depleted
countries in the world and perhaps we
should adopt a more humble approach to
countries with far more impressive
conservation records rather than in
Consulting rather than insulting we
should be Consulting Africans on this
issue and I'm really grateful to the
government for recognizing that I'm also
grateful to my honorable friend the
member for Crawley who I know like me
passionately cares about animals and we
just have to debate in this chamber of
the differences of our opinion to make
sure that everybody comes on that
journey to a better future for our
children and our planet thank you
thank you very much Madam Deputy speaker
I'm here today to support my honorable
friend for crawl is very important bill
to ban United Kingdom Imports of trophy
hunting trophies
I should begin by declaring a personal
interest
in that this was a particular passion of
our great friend the late surveillance
I knew David for over 20 years in part
although he was elected far earlier than
me
on the 9th of June 1983. coincidentally
as I understand it on the same day as my
right honorable friend for Christchurch
I must confess to the house that I'm not
an expert in this subject
but I do know
that my late friend desperately wanted
legislation of this type to pass
so I hope the house will simply
understand my motive for being here
today
it's very good to be supported in this
task by his excellent successor The
Honorable member for South and West who
was in her place beside me
among those watching the debate on this
crucial goal very closely
we're members of the conservative Animal
Welfare Foundation
led by its redial offender this is the
rain plant he was campaigned tirelessly
on this issue and indeed many others
relating to Animal Welfare for years
she was also a great friend of Sir
David's and I know that she and her
organization will also be wishing this
bill well it is almost as if she was
with us here today
on the 2nd of October 2019 sir David in
the Westminster Hall debate
on trophy hunting Imports said this I
quote him
I recognize there is no easy solution
two hundred thousand endangered animals
are put at risk each year which is an
awful lot to deal with
it's so depressing that as soon as
someone comes up with an idea to stop
Trophy Hunters these evil Wicked people
get ahead of the game and find some way
around the legislation
I don't mean to provoke my honorable
friend for North herefordshire because
he and I came into this place on the
same day in 2001.
but sir David in 2019 went on to say I
don't minimize the difficulty that the
government face
but I simply cannot comprehend why
anyone
would pay up to 72 000 to travel across
the world and shoot a beautiful animal
as I've said at business questions I've
seen numerous adverts for trophy hunting
with some companies even advertising
price lists by tripling by animal on
offer and by trophy fee
such adverts should be completely banned
from all Platforms in the United Kingdom
yeah yeah
I hope in this deliberately brief
contribution Madam Deputy speaker
I've been able to make my point
David was cruelly taken from us
and absolutely tragic circumstances
but his memory lives on yeah he was an
absolutely amazing Champion for Animal
Welfare and I hope it's not presumptuous
I'm honored to stand here today
perhaps in lieu of him supported by his
worthy successor to make the case
for this vital Bill if he would hear if
he were here he would thank my honorable
friend and indeed the entire house
for what they are about to do
so may I humbly
say thank you as well
thank you madam Deputy speaker and I
Rise also as the member of South End
West not only to extend my
congratulations to my honorable friend
the member for Crawley for His Brilliant
leadership in bringing this important
bill to its final stages in the House of
Commons but also to remember the late
sir David amos's
decades-long advocacy on this issue and
I thank my right honorable friend for
Rayleigh and Whitford for his
contribution and what he has also said
about Sir David I know that sir David
would have supported my colleagues Bill
he would have been cheering him on at
every stage of its passage and it's been
my huge honor to support this bill at
every stage as well not just in sir
David's honor and Legacy but because
this is the right thing to do and in sir
David's place I would just like to say
that through this bill we are asserting
that these magnificent animals elephants
Lions rhinos leopards Etc many of whom
of course I give way
thank you
um so David was very kind to me from the
the first day I came into Parliament and
he encouraged me to work on Animal
Welfare matters and it's very
appropriate that Eduardo konkar was his
latest book
segan Sally Trophy Hunter secret and
lies is dedicated to the memory of Sir
David
thank you madam Deputy speaker and I I
Thank The Honorable member very much for
that contribution which I will pass on
to Lady Amos and the family uh
these wonderful magnificent animals
which some of which are on the brink of
Extinction are worth so much more than a
mere trophy on the mantelpiece trophy
hunting is a relic of the past it has no
place in modern Britain and we are
standing as one in this house to stand
up against those who seek to destroy
wildlife and instead assert our leading
role as an advocate for wildlife
protection
I'll be very very brief I know many
members would have loved to have speak
spoken's debate today I just wanted to
pay tribute to the member for honorable
member from Crawley for this today but
also to those members from North
Heritage and Christchurch for doing
something which has enabled this
incredible the important bill to
safeguard animals to go through
um my very brief point is that we've
seen an outpouring Across the Nation for
this bill we've seen support in the
chamber from all members we've seen
support from the government and
ultimately from the general public I
just want to pay tribute to all of those
and thank them for that now like myself
I'm sure many members here today have
canceled constituency events to be here
to support the Bell so I support it
wholeheartedly and thank the house for
all of their support for it too thank
you
Shadow minister
Alex so
yeah thank you madam depth to speaker
it's a real pleasure to be able to stand
up and and speak so quickly in this
debate I'm not sure we quite thought we
were going to get here this quickly but
I'm so pleased that we are the lay party
is strongly committed to a ban on
Hunting trophy in ports reflected by the
number of colleagues here on a Friday on
all sides of the house in fact it was a
Manifesto commitment of ours at the last
election I'm therefore I'd like to say
that we shall be supporting this bill
today I'd like to start my paint trip to
the late labor MP for waveny Bob
blizzard who's one of the founders of
the campaign to burn trophy hunting and
this bill is part of his legacy I'd like
to thank his partner Jane Evans and
friend Eduardo con garves have worked
tirelessly on the campaign of in
particular help to me I also want to
Echo members across the house actually
in their tribute to David Amos and his
work on this matter like The Honorable
member for Crawley and people across the
country I was shocked and horrified the
killing of Cecil the lion but American
Trophy Hunter in 2015 I was horrified
the needlessly cruel manner in which
Cecil died he'd been left to drown in
his own lung blood simply because the
hunter wanted to win a special prize for
shooting a line with a bow and arrow
however I was even more shocked and
horrified to learn that since 2015
British trophy has been brought back
more than 100 trophies Alliance from
Africa into the UK indeed what British
Hunters are doing is I'd be worse than
what Cecil suffered because he lived in
the wild in Zimbabwe and was 13 when he
was killed
some British Trophy Hunters on the other
hand fly to Africa where they shoot tame
lines have been hand reared since
they're born merely to become a hunter's
trophy but it turns out the Lions aren't
the only African animals that British
Hunters are shooting they're shooting
trophy many other threatened species in
Africa and around the world and all of
this has happened since 2015 a year when
the world supposedly woke up to the
horror of trophy until the year and we
all thought the killing of Cecil would
bring us to our senses and put an end
this Horror Story once and for all how
wrong we were we considered ourselves a
nation of animal lovers and rightly so
however the things that British Trophy
Hunters do should shame us all
here are the prizes just one British
Trophy and there's one from Safari Club
International the hunting achievement
Diamond award for shooting animals from
125 different species the animals of
Africa Gold Award for shooting at least
61 different African animals the global
hunting gold order shooting 50 different
animals on five different continents the
British hunter in question gone to an
over 30 more of these Awards Safari Club
International which handed out this
price as a branch here in Britain it's
been actively working to undermine and
block the bill that we are considering
today to spend over 1 million pounds on
a disinformation campaign I know other
members have mentioned this already
investigation by The Washington Post
reveal it to be the work of an ally of
Donald Trump whose real set of a number
of fake news groups to promote extreme
rhyming course and try to create an
AstroTurf campaign
Africans are as shocked and horrified
trophy as we are they're vehemently
opposed to people jetting in from around
the world to wipe out their Wildlife a
natural heritage for so-called sport
there was a very recent past Africa The
Hub of the African trophy hundred and
she showed that even they're fully 68 of
people are against trophy hunting many
of us including myself recently received
a letter from the form president
Botswana cerretze Ian Kammer he banned
all trophy hunting in his country he
tells us how Banning trophy not only
benefited threatened species such as
elephant Botswana is now home to
one-third of all Africa's elephants it
also brought prosperity to local
communities creating more jobs and
opportunities for local people and
improving living conditions by investing
in Photo Safaris instead the example of
Kenya which ban trophy in the 1970s won
should be applaud and encouraged while
lion elephant and Rhino populations are
falling through amateur Africa their
numbers are all increasing in Kenya and
it is of economic benefit to those
people as well we can just compare the
conditions of the Kenyan Maasai with
those at Tanzania next door where trophy
hunting is still legal which includes 20
000 Tanzanian Maasai being homeless due
to land clearance it is time to act we
can say that it's wrong for British
people to kill animals for pleasure and
Mentos we can set an example Raj and
Pope Benjamin zephanite perhaps put it
best when he says we human beings our
responsibility to look after this planet
and its animals we need to put trophy
hunting in the Dustbin of history on
slave trade female infanticide and witch
hunting
it's a pleasure to do something
vulnerable friend for giving away and
welcome the passage of this bill not
least because I won't have to move my
own bill on the next next Friday but
is there a danger that we might be in
slightly complacent given how far
Advanced we are in the Parliamentary
calendar that this bill will pass with
overwhelming support in this house but
the question is whether those some of
those elements that he's been describing
may try and exercise delay in the other
house and has he sought any response
from the minister that the government
will ensure that that doesn't happen if
necessary creating extra parliamentary
time in order to do so
yeah I'd like to thank your November for
his intervention I I've had had very
fruitful discussion with the minister
who I'm sure will respond to his point
when she speaks but I know that the
government are as Keen as we are see
this uh trophy hunting bill on the
statute books this is not an issue of
division between our parties I'll just
finish by finishing my quote from
Benjamin cefanar where he says let's
support the hunting trophies import
prohibition Bill and so I'd like to
conclude and hope that we can get this
bill through shortly thank you
Minister Julia
thank you madam Deputy speaker and thank
you to all members here who are able to
contribute to this debate but let me
start by thanking the members who sadly
are not here and able to contribute to
this debate yet they have been
instrumental in enabling this day to
happen and in particular I refer to our
honorable friend the
um the member for South End West who was
taken far too soon but yet his
contribution to this place was more than
many of us will ever make and I think
the member for raelian Wickford set that
out and most eloquently and also the
member for Waverly who cannot be here to
debate such a subject that was so
important to him and actually Madam
Deputy speaker dare I say that Cecil
the lion
has not died in vain
it's an emotional day for all of us for
very uh many
um reasons but I'm really pleased to be
here to support this bill once more of
course I need to pay tribute to my
honorable member uh my honorable friend
the member for Crawley once again for
his efforts in getting the bill to this
nearly final stage and in response to uh
the member opposite who raised his
concern and I can't say it's not my
concern too I want this bill and I know
members in here today want this bill to
pass through the other place as well and
I'm grateful actually for the meeting I
had this morning with um
my friends opposite uh the members for
Alden West and royton and also for Leeds
North in discussing just how that might
be possible because it is of such
significance to all parties I believe
across this house
briefly I will can I thank the minister
for forgiving way and it looks as though
we've got more time in the Parliamentary
calendar running up to the to the Autumn
but can the government send a very clear
message to any who might be tempted to
cause disruption and delay in the other
place which for those listening is how
we refer to the House of Lords and uh
and in order to ensure that there is
sufficient parliamentary time to make
sure that this measure goes through in
this Parliament
yeah
he invites me to make promises which I'm
simply unable to guarantee I'm afraid in
terms of timings but I think it is worth
me explaining that some of the concerns
both raised here and which will be
raised in The Other Place refer to how
we will ensure we support the countries
that will be affected by this ban on
Imports of trophies and so I'd like to
briefly set out the work that the
government is undertaken for example 90
million pounds for the Darwin initiative
and Darwin plus to address biodiversity
challenges and support local communities
30 million pounds for action on illegal
Wildlife trade and the 100 million
pounds biodiverse Landscapes fund to
work across six Landscapes to protect
and restore critical terrestrial
ecosystems I do recognize that some of
the income from trophy hunting has
contributed towards the protection of
habitat and the prevention of poaching
but to bring the body parts of
endangered species as clearly set out in
cities one and two lists is not the way
forward this government recognizes that
this country recognizes that and I am
absolutely clear that
um it is time for change
it is absolutely what the public expects
we know this because over 85 percent of
the respondents to the consultation made
it clear though it will remain
controversial and that is why I was
willing to accept new Clause 4 to set up
that Advisory Board to the government
um as requested by my honorable friend
and also to respect the work that cities
does internationally which is why we
were willing to accept the amendment
Amendment one by a minorable friend from
northamptonshire I will give way
the only lady makes a very important
Point further to the intervention
earlier about the support there is for
this cross-party support members here
from both sides of the houses all of us
wanting this to proceed well at the
other place does she agree with me that
now this concession has been made a
generous concession I might add to
curtail significantly the
regulation-making powers in Clause two
that there is really nothing for their
Lordships to object to normally they
object to so-called Henry VII Powers
those have been completely removed and
that should therefore be possible to
expedite the process of this bill at the
other place
my radical friend is absolutely correct
and it is absolutely the reason why we
have accepted this amendment because we
want this bill to progress not just in
the Commons but also in the Lords as
well
um and I would just like to correct I
was referring to my uh member for North
northamptonshire earlier I think Madam
Deputy speaker what I actually meant to
say was north herefordshire
um so to to make some further progress
the import ban will cover all species
listed on Annex A and B of our Wildlife
trade regulations broadly aligned with
appendix one and two of cities and this
extends to around 6 000 species
including those mentioned in this house
I would like to take the opportunity to
recognize again the concerns that have
been raised about Northern Ireland and
the risk
um that my honorable friend
um
referred to about Northern Ireland
somehow becoming a back door
um the member for East Antrim queried
how we would make progress and clearly
set out that he very much wants to be
part of the UK but let me reassure the
house that we will do everything we
possibly can to ensure that this is not
the case that Northern Ireland will not
be a back door for so-called trophies
from endangered species to enter
Scotland England or Wales it will not be
a stepping stone for imports to Great
Britain in committee we discussed the
workings of the bill and how it operates
alongside the Northern Ireland protocol
and the UK internal market and since
then the government has published The
Windsor framework
I will give way
I thank the most for giving way
I hope that Amir is clear that it's not
my concern is not only at Northern
Ireland could become a back door
that is a concern but also that Northern
Ireland will be exempt from this
legislation so that people who engage in
trophy hunting can operate freely in
Northern Ireland the northern protocol
doesn't stop it the Windsor framework
doesn't stop it can the minister give us
an assurance that the government will
take action to stop Imports coming into
Northern Ireland full stop just as it
would be coming into their ban from the
rest of the United Kingdom
put on record madame Madame Deputy
speaker our current controls on Imports
will continue to apply to Northern
Ireland under the current cities
controls in line with the Northern
Ireland protocol and the Windsor
framework we will continue to in to
scrutinize import permit applications
carefully making sure that they're not
going to be moved onwards and movements
of hunting trophies from Northern
Ireland to Great Britain will be subject
to the import ban unless they
um are qualifying Northern Ireland Goods
in line with the UK internal Market act
but we will continue to review this and
absolutely continue to work with the
honorable gentleman as we make progress
I will give away thank you Minister for
giving away and she says that she will
so the government will seek to do this
through using the cities legislation Etc
if that were the case then of course
there's no need for this bill this bill
is required because there is additional
action needed to stop people going and
cruelly hunting down animals in other
parts of the world and bringing back his
trophies to the United Kingdom what I
want to know is how does she intend to
ensure that Northern Ireland Trophy
Hunters do not have license which they
don't have in other parts of the United
Kingdom
my honorable friend does make um a
convincing point but it should be
recognized that this is a brexit
opportunity we wouldn't be able to make
this progress across Great Britain if we
were still within the European Union it
is not ideal I'll be the first person to
state that quite clearly we want to make
further progress we will I'm sure make
further progress and I will continue to
to meet and I know that my officials
will be meeting with those in Northern
Ireland as well
um in terms of
I'm most grateful but does she accept
that apparently in the Netherlands
despite them being within the European
Union they have imposed a complete ban
on trophy Imports if they can do it in
the Netherlands why can't it be done in
respect of Northern Ireland
I'm Adam Deputy speaker you will um
excuse me from being drawn into this
wider argument getting back to the Crux
of this debate since the bills committee
we've published the environmental
Improvement plan setting out our goal in
the UK and across um our uh our country
to see thriving plants and Wildlife
um and how we're going to achieve this
here the UK is supporting other
countries to take action working
together with a shared commitment to
Halt and reverse biodiversity loss by
2030. as we agreed at the UN nature
Summit 15 in Montreal last year
um I know there are great many other uh
bills that we want to get through today
so in closing I must again thank and
commend my honorable friend the member
for Crawley for his Relentless
determination and uh members across the
house in particular I want to thank the
member for Neath who I have met with I
know she feels passionately about this
subject and I was pleased to work with
her
um my honorable friends on the the front
bench who have worked very collegiately
to make sure that we pass this bill in
this house and I'm incredibly grateful
for that I'm pleased that members have
contributed not just today but
previously and we are sending a very
strong message to the rest of the world
that in this country where we can we are
demonstrating our support for endangered
species as set out by cities across the
world and we do not accept their body
parts being used as so-called fees to be
brought back into this country
Jen is that the bill be now read the
third time as many as are of that
opinion say I
of the country no
I think the eyes have it and
have it